[Music]
hi we're at the 2019 Wolfram technology
conference I'm Sylvia hast and I'm a
Wolfram Alpha on Twitter and this is my
co-host
I'm sure the Ponte and I was a student
at Wolfram camp in 2019 and we're here
with Andrew Stein ocker who is a lead
developer at Wolfram and he's gonna be
talking about his Arduino gas mileage
tracker so Andrew what do you do it will
friend ha I work for Wolfram Alpha and I
work on the Food and Nutrition content
normally but I also do some data science
projects on the side as well so what I'm
here to present several couple data
science projects um just like this one
so yeah so it's ready to show people how
to use Wolfram language for data science
projects and other things too so what is
your gas mileage record right so I have
an Arduino that is connected to my cars
canvas or the obd2 port as its called
and it just listens to all the traffic
that's on there it's a huge fire hose of
data and I've been really interested but
I actually got started in it when I you
know when I was in high school I always
had to keep track with my gas mileage to
be able to know how much it was costing
me to drive everywhere and manage things
that way that's why I had a spreadsheet
that I just would punch stuff into and
keep track of things that way and so I
always thought it was really fascinating
to like keep track of that stuff because
really wasn't really all that helpful
and required a lot of manual effort a
lot to keep track of so I a couple years
ago I there's blog post month
right where I used the Wolfram cloud via
to create a webform that I could access
on my phone and every time I got gas I
would just punch in the numbers and it
would dump the contents intraday to Ben
and I could do analysis on it and make
some nice like automated updated
reporting and that kind of stuff as well
so how long have you been tracking uh
for quite a while now I think around 20s
mid 2016 I want to say so several years
now on that stuff yeah absolutely
so um these are just two plots right
here um that I've done on some of the
data so as you can see here your MA
basically this is the gas mileage I
measured both the computed and the
actual gas mileage if you want to think
of it that way the computed stuff is
what my car has so there's a little
display that it thinks what the gas
mileage is for the trip how am I believe
that's the blue line and the the actual
one is the lower one which is the the
orange colored one and so they're mostly
on track so I kind of was interested in
finding out how accurate that meter was
that turns out it's pretty accurate
sometimes it's a little optimistic but
for the most part they agree for the
most part there and I was also
interested in you know like you know
seasonality and that kind of stuff to
see you know when it's cold outside does
it get worse and that kind of stuff and
so you can kind of see a little bit of
that in the colder times you can see it
kinda down down the beginning of the
year it gets pretty chilly and so then
you know I have to look a car warm up
more and you know things are not quite
as efficient family yeah yeah so I keep
track of the price and where they are
and that kind of stuff and and this is
this is kind of nice
because it's nice and fine-grained and
it's fairly low tech in some sense
because you can just put it in into a
web form but I knew that that that
display that was in my car was keeping
track of much more information of that
and I really wondered how am I gonna get
to that information cuz I really want
that I want to know on a per trick basis
so I did a bunch of research and I built
a little circuit here with
you know you can kind of see it here's
what the cervical artery no sandwiches
it might be called Heather's an Arduino
on the bottom and a canvas field in the
middle and then at the very top there's
an SD card shield and basically what I
do is I plug in to this port here where
I with this db9 port here and that
connects to my car's obd2 port I think
all cars the newer than like 2008 have
to have that port that's underneath the
steering wheel on the side a little bit
and basically they communicate over a
protocol called can where basically it's
just like two wires that all all of the
computers in the car can communicate
with and the nice thing about is that
all devices can hear all devices
messages so I can just passively listen
on just kind of sniff the the traffic
that's on there and log it straight to
the SD card and I log it in binary as
fast as I can because it turns out
there's a lot of data being thrown
around so I've had to do some tricks to
to speed things up so how much data do
you that so far since I've been
gathering data for gosh probably a year
and a half or so now I've probably got
about 16 gigabytes of binary data so
it's actually might be more like 20 at
this point it's been a while since I've
checked the actual number but it's
definitely a few thousand trips for sure
so it's pretty large that way so so as I
was doing this I was manually ingesting
the files and kind of manually building
time series and things like that out of
them but instead I found it easier to
write something in the Wolfram language
to be able to programmatically do this
so I built a little tool called kin GUI
so catice you know the protocol online
so it's a GUI so it's a little
interactive interface and so what I've
done here is I built something where you
can select a date of all the trips that
I have and you can choose the dates and
times for trips so for example if I just
picked this one on I will just choose PI
day for now
and you can select a specific thing that
I found like here for example the
accelerator pedal and it will
dynamically update this little display
here I know it's not the prettiest of
displays but it was much faster than
manually moving things around and so you
can see the messages that are there on
this side and the frequency at which
they're done and basically there's no
manual that comes with any of this it's
all a lot of reverse engineering kinds
of things so I'm basically what I've got
is a little thing here that allows me to
punch in what ID what message ID is
there I can give it a name and I can
write a function that's able to take in
the the bytes of the content there
because each one sends about 8 bytes of
data and then I can attach units to them
I can resample them at certain grades
draw
you know ranges and that sort of thing
to find all kinds of cool stuff so like
that's my gas pedal information probably
most interesting that I found was the
fuel flow which with some tools that I
wrote to be able to manipulate bytes in
different orders whether they're for
unsigned integers or signed integers
kind of very low-level stuff once you
can play with some of that stuff I've
got things cooked up here so with this
just with the little factor in front
that I found Isle fits really well with
the fuel flow so for example here you
kind of see what it looks like in terms
of gallons per hour for a given trip
there the nice thing is I'm able to find
individual real speeds as well and so if
I can use the speedometer I can actually
divide the two and I you know have to
have some factors in there to actually
correct it to get it right and I clip it
so that it'll actually you know not
giving me a million miles to the gallon
if I'm coasting you can kind of see um
when I stop you know I my gas mileage
you know taps out but if I'm coasting
you know it caps out and say a hundred
that seemed like a reasonable number
choose
so yeah there's quite a lot of
information here it's a lot of
experimentation and research to go try
and find rings including things like the
so I found this was a lot with a stirrer
to work with than manually doing
everything point-and-click was much
easier to work it wasn't too hard to do
with dynamic module so how would the
average person project right so um if
anyone is interested in actually doing
cans sniffing they would have to you
know hook up a similar device like I
have to their car luckily most cars
operate on can and you know operate
about the same speed so it's not too
terribly hard to listen to as far as the
actual data coming in you know it
differs from car to car manufacturer to
manufacturer it might have a little
trouble that way if they choose the same
format that I've built for it then yeah
this tool would be accessible to others
and it's available on github and other
things too I might be getting more
action if it operates on can I think all
I have to do is just plug it in and then
I would just have to relearn where all
the information is so yeah absolutely
one of the things that I've done
recently is I built an entity store to
handle all of my trips so these are like
actual entity objects that I've used
with properties that are aligned to
those things that I've found so here for
example this is gas a great little kind
of together as you can kinda see that
keep the brakes on when I don't have the
gas on and so on and so forth for the
most part so I've also done some other
things and aligned it to my the form
that I was mentioning earlier and it
turns out they agreed pretty well so the
blue line is actually the line of fit on
those being kind of seee they're they're
a little off in a few places but you
know that has to do with you know not
quite perfect things or if I can't
always have a plug
running in that kind of stuff so I've
done some heat analysis with like trends
per month when I started to collect GPS
data for a while it's not super detailed
so you can kind of see like a single
trip here that you know kind of shows a
single trip but the read sort of shows
the accuracy so it's not super accurate
I have been collecting a lot of data on
various places and as I travel around
and stuff like that and the nice thing
is I can zoom in on like specific areas
much more closely so you can see I'm on
champagne here that's that's a nice grid
so I can use these rectangles to kind of
see everything so yeah in the future I
think what I want to do is investigate
more more messages try and figure out
they are try and live stream them onto a
computer so I can get more feedback and
then you know do nicer things with like
detecting when someone's driving whether
it's me or someone else and learn
driving patterns and analyze the actual
paths through which I Drive learn
something that you weren't expecting to
about your driving patterns not not
really so much I think I found that I
take almost the exact same route much
more but yeah definitely a creature of
habit in some ways but yeah I've always
wondered some intersections if they're
really slow and turns out they are quite
a bit slower than others
yes thank you so much for joining us
today in this room this is really
awesome
[Music]